thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler millions of people are
traveling for thanksgiving
despite calls from health officials to
stay home numbers are
lower than normal for holiday travel but
flights are going in and out of mccarran
all day long
we have kate houston there this
afternoon with a look and kate you spoke
with travelers about their decision to
fly this holiday season
yes that's right mccarran airport
officials tell me they can't put an
exact number on the amount of flights or
passengers here
because normally they base that off of
years before
but during the holiday season that's
really anything but normal
passengers tell me they still felt safe
on their flights now to assist in that
effort
mccarran is doubling down on its safety
protocols
the airport is limiting the amount of
people allowed inside the building
only ticketed passengers can go inside
at this time
many of the passengers i spoke to said
there were strict safety protocols at
airports they were flying from
such as atlanta and denver with cases of
covet 19 continuing to climb
including here in nevada i asked
passengers about their decision to
travel during the pandemic
it's a hectic time but i still think
that family is very important so
i'm happy that know the flights are
still going on you're able to go see
your family
i felt better traveling with him since i
lived with him so it's not like i had to
sit next to strangers and that kind of
stuff
i really feel very peaceful about it i
think
it's really the safest time to fly
although there is a dip in passengers
flying nationwide
mccarran airport advises if you are
flying get here
early some of the parking lots can fill
up quickly and the added safety measures
may increase wait times aaa nevada says
that las vegas is one of the top hotel
destinations on the west coast for
thanksgiving
if you are planning to head outside of
the city though aaa suggests checking on
any new safety guidelines that may be in
place reporting from mccarran airport
keith houston 8 news now